This is Josh Radner.
这是乔什·拉德纳。
I am here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hi, Josh.
嗨，乔什。
Hey, it's great to be here with you.
嘿，很高兴和你在一起。
Welcome to the first episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》第一集。
Are we calling it Whimium?
我们称之为 Whimium 吗？
I was wondering about that.
我对此感到好奇。
Whimium.
惠米姆。
I think it's Whimium.
我认为是惠米姆。
This weekly re-watch premieres on Monday, March 10th.
每周重播将于 3 月 10 日星期一首播。
Listen on Apple Podcasts or anywhere you get your podcasts and watch us on YouTube.
在 Apple 播客或任何可以获取播客的地方收听并在 YouTube 上观看我们的节目。
Learn more at How we major mother dot com much like the older wiser narrator Ted, which we are now around that age.
了解更多信息，请参阅我们如何主要母亲点com就像年长而明智的叙述者泰德一样，我们现在大约在那个年龄。
Let's look back and see who we were, who we are now, where we're going.
让我们回顾一下，看看我们曾经是谁，现在是谁，我们要去哪里。
When I see you, he's permit me to tell you everything book city.
当我见到你时，他允许我告诉你书城的一切。